oh Jesus that's how you were dead
[Music]
Aaron you played farcry new dawn last
week and you've had some pretty positive
opinions on it so far but it is a little
bit different than previous Far Cry
games right yeah one of the really
interesting things about far cry new
dawn is this time around boobies
not only like acknowledging it's the
same map I remember last time there was
some controversy over people discovering
that primal is on the same map but this
game is actually written to exist on the
same map so if you got to the end of Far
Cry 5 some bad things happen to the
world
spoilers and that kind of set up this I
don't know what it is it gets a sequel a
different main character though right
totally and it's same deal where you
create your own character again right
yeah so you start fresh the overarching
stories basically a bunch of people got
together and they made a new town called
prosperity and the Highwaymen show up
and mess up their day in typical Mad Max
fashion there's this guy up and down the
coast named Thomas Rush who's teaching
communities how to defend themselves in
your part of his security detail you get
spit out into the world when his train
gets ambushed and then it's your job in
typical fashion to mess up and get
prosperity back up in action
[Music]
now how that actually works is new
there's a lot of new elements to the
game that are RPG inspired and for the
first time you're shooting highwaymen
and other bad guys in Far Cry and
numbers are popping out of their head
Borderlands style so yeah that does kind
of sound like a shooter RPG now the
interesting bit about this is the
mechanics seem like a good solution to
longevity in the game's previous Far Cry
games you kind of go around you clear
all the outposts and usually the the
only thing you can do at that point is
just reset the outpost and do it again
so the RPG systems in Far Cry New Dawn
are there basically this you take an
outpost and you can then reclaim the
resources from that outpost or just
leave it if you reclaim the resources
then the highwayman move back into that
outpost and they are tougher they're a
higher level enemy it's something like
one through four one through five
there's like a gold king level enemy
that's the toughest there's a crafting
system and prosperity that is the
equivalent to that so you start off with
like grey weapons and you go to purple
weapons and then you eventually end up
at Gold weapons I think it's it's again
like one through four now are there
random loot drops or is it only based on
crafting it seems to be mostly based on
crafting but in the same vein as far cry
5 you can pick up an enemy weapon and
suddenly it's in your inventory to have
okay so it's cool like I much prefer
that system where you can pick up and
keep weapons but you're definitely gonna
have to craft so for example we hit an
outpost at level 1
we played solo and co-op and it was easy
we just breeze through it and then we
tried to go back to that outpost at
level 2 and couldn't do it like we you
you can't execute people they take a lot
more bullets to kill ok so it's like
similar to Assassin's Creed where you
can't stealth assassinate unless you are
at a certain level like how does that
work does your blade you get up you get
a higher level knife or something like
that in the unlock tree and farcry
there's always been just higher levels
of assassinations seeing you get like
ones with body armor but I'm curious
like so just a standard dude like if you
go up to him and take him out but he's
like a level 2 in your level one where
you
not be able to completely yeah okay I'm
flying a tower to stealth assassinate
one of their spotters and I just
couldn't do it he just took it and it's
cool because the app boats get harder
now every time you scavenge an outpost
you get the resource ethanol and that
lets you go in expeditions around so
there's a helicopter pilot and you buy
expeditions from him those expeditions
actually also get progressively harder
the more times you do them one thing
that makes this different from say
primal which took place on the same map
is that these expeditions let you go to
other places in the country and do these
they're instances but interesting levels
like one was an aircraft carrier and the
other was a dam
so these systems feed on themselves like
the game gets tougher you craft better
weapons which like the weapons look
cooler too as they get better they some
of the high level weapons had they're
kind of funny because they're very Mad
Max but had a screwdriver attached to
the front like they look beat up and
taped together the style that the art
style is really cool something I'm a bit
concerned about though is and we'll see
how this plays out because I didn't see
this in the preview event but I noticed
the you play points allow you to unlock
your gold tier shotgun and some of the
pre-order bonuses let you get gold tier
weapons and vehicles and I don't know
what that'll do to the difficulty of the
game like it might break the difficulty
if you just start with a gold tier
weapon yeah that's a good point I guess
we'll have to find out when it comes out
how do the vehicles look are there lots
of sort of Mad Max post-apocalyptic
looking vehicles around to that you can
pilot and drive yeah the Highwaymen
drive around and pretty beat-up vehicles
and the ones that you can craft also and
again like there's a tiered crafting
system for vehicles also they get
progressively more beat-up and
cool-looking but to your point with
vehicles and how this game recognizes
that you're coming back to the same
place over and over again so if you
remember in Far Cry 5 you fly Nick Rhys
airplane for the first time and you do
his mission
yeah so you can you can find Nick again
in this game and actually a large
portion of this game is based around his
family particularly them the daughter
that you delivered at the end of [ __ ]
yeah I think that was an optional quest
to like I don't think everyone had to do
that if they didn't want to which if you
haven't done it you should go back and
do that mission because it'll give you a
much larger attachment to this world
particularly because she's such a main
character in it mm-hmm so you can find
Nick again and you mirror the same
mission with his airplane but his
airplane doesn't have any wings this
time because it's it's just the beat up
apocalypse right yeah
so you do a similar mission but it's all
just a pontoon boat aircraft on the
ground shooting enemies so new dawn does
a really fun job of taking you back to
the same places all over again but
giving you a new perspective on this
places
[Music]
hey baby
hey you know if you're busy I can always
come back you know
what about hired guns that was a pretty
big thing in Far Cry 5 is that back
hired guns are back there are new ones
some of them are similar to far cry 5
for example we did a mission to rescue
timber who was basically the same as
boomer it was like cuter his mission his
mission will give you a little bit of
feels because you're trying to figure
out what he's doing the whole time okay
and then when you find out what he wants
you to do he's a good doggy
bad dog there's also Horatio who's a
bore we didn't see him but did loves me
some cheeseburger the bear oh is he back
from far cry 5 we didn't see him
I think the boar is the is gonna be like
the new cheeseburger the new
cheeseburger maybe hamburger yeah
anything else you want to add about your
time with far cry new dawn it's a so the
bass games not full price it's it's more
far cry you know talking to some of the
other people in the office who didn't
like far cry 5 as much I don't think
there's anything here if you didn't like
far cry 5 that would make you suddenly
like it but if you did like far cry 5
like I did and you're attached to the
characters this is a great continuation
of those characters I like I ran into
the he's on the poster art so this is
not not a spoiler but like I ran into
the father at one point the way that
they ended Far Cry 5 really makes you
wonder what they could possibly be doing
next and this is that they just went
straight into the post apocalypse and
honestly like it's got the humor of Far
Cry one of the characters at the event
his name was little effort which like we
we would have to bleep out if we started
talking about him yeah
but the writings very like mature you
know if you deliver the baby in Far Cry
5 you're instantly attached to the
characters we'll see how the crafting
system plays out it seems like a good
way to make the outposts more
interesting and last longer so yeah like
overall I think if you like Far Cry 5
this is kind of an easy yes yeah and
it's a good continuation of of that
story yeah it was interesting because
after I got to the end of Far Cry 5 a
lot of people got into Far Cry 5 they're
like well they're obviously gonna go to
apocalypse but I don't think anyone
expected it to be dis soon so it's
pretty neat especially if you enjoyed it
because I came out what less than a year
ago now
and this one comes out February 15th on
Xbox Playstation 4 and PC and for more
on that game make sure to stay tuned to
games by
[Music]
you